ladies and gentlemen Will Ferrell and
Steve Carell
of all the tools an actor has in
creating the perfect look for a part
none is more important than the skillful
use of makeup
well said Steve makeup artists are the
magicians of the movie industry
transforming actors and actresses into
gods and goddesses of perfect appearance
through techniques handed down by the
master practitioners of their craft for
over 5,000 years the makeup artists
commitment to excellence is
all-consuming and we would not be who we
are without them by the way will you
look great
thank you you look great too man you
smell really good too
that's what you're wearing it's called
pineapple bliss
are you alright that's my eyelashes the
nominees for achievement in makeup are
Howard Berger and Tammy Lane for The
Chronicles of Narnia
The Lion the Witch and the Wardrobe
David Leroy Anderson and Lance Anderson
for Cinderella man
Dave L Z and Nikki gully for Star Wars
Episode three Revenge of the Sith and
the Oscar goes to Howard Berger and
Tammy Lane for the Chronicles of Narnia
the Lion the Witch and
this is the first Oscar nomination for
our burger and Tammy Lane
well I'm just glad that Clooney doesn't
do makeup so I'm not worked out well
well this is really an amazing life and
and it all started when I was a little
boy and my mother read me where the wild
things are by Maurice Sendak and at that
point I knew I wanted to go live with
the monsters real quick I want to thank
Disney Mark Johnson Walden Media Kari
granite Perry more my partners in crime
that can be effects group Robert
Kurtzman and Greg Nicotero everyone that
was there with me through the journey a
year and a half of this magnificent
project my aslan Andrew Adamson my
inspiration kelsey Travis and Jake my
best friend sandy Rick Baker dick Smith
Stan Winston Richard Taylor Danny Street
PAC and I want to dedicate this to my
parents Kenneth and Susan burger right
now I know they're looking down upon me
and saying we're proud of you that you
are living with the monsters and running
through the forth of the wild things
thank you thanks
I have to say congratulations to the
Chronicles of Narnia for that that
really was an amazing makeup job I'm a
little surprised Cinderella man didn't
win that category I just think you know
imagine the difficulty in making russell
crowe looked like he got into a fight
but just that's uh i'm gonna be pummeled
later this evening are not very nice can
i get Luke can I get a shot behind me of
this statue by any chance real quick can
we see that do you think that if we all
got together and pulled this down
democracy would flourish in Hollywood
Jimmy Caan would grab a sandal and just
start hitting it